we went to norway okay we went to norway
um super [ __ ] north so north to see
uh orca whales
you ever seen orcas in real life
beautiful creatures right we heard they
were in norway
like the most north you can get without
being on the north [ __ ] bowl
um and this is after you know my dog
chewed my passport we were supposed to
go to uganda to capture gorillas for
this project that got canceled because
my dog chewed my passport i'm like
scrambling to make it to stodd
uh heli just ski off a mountain
parachute down head right to norway and
a [ __ ] friend's billionaire's private
jet like this like that type of journey
like every day back to [ __ ] james
bond [ __ ] no stupid dude and my friend
who invited me on this trip
invited like five
highly accomplished men from different
fields
and each person was so good at what they
did it was like a three-day mastermind
retreat of just dudes hanging out
sleeping three hours a night roughing it
through these cities going super [ __ ]
north and trying to swim with an orca
whales
where
in in tromso north of tromso um norway
where the sun does not come up over the
horizon at this time of year
it's light
for two hours
light in the pitch black the hardest
i've worked to ever get a photo ever and
guess what polar it doesn't capture in
low light
one of the most epic stories that i
learned
the most ever in three days with with um
the head like uh economist the head
survivalist had um um um philanthropist
like the uh uh kygo was with us in one
wing of the journey like because he's
it's [ __ ] crazy how much i learned
from this trick do you know who mike
horn is
no man the world needs to know this guy
who is he
survivalist extremist extraordinaire
swam down the amazon river like all by
himself across the across the world he's
he's circumference the world like a
multitude of times one time he did it
around the equator he followed the
equator went all the way around the
world on the equator he had to like
outsmart militaries and like
go through like the most unimaginable
conquest just to survive
survivalist so hearing this dude's
stories aren't like
the stories i'm telling now this is like
yo i i
here's how i caught monkeys to survive
on the
amazon whoa monkey see monkey do he'd
lick a a plant in the morning set it
down the monkey comes and gets the salt
runs back up the tree and he kept doing
that every day and tricked the monkey
and saying that he was able to catch it
right so he's telling these stories
about about survival about [ __ ] like
you i don't i don't want to i don't like
out his [ __ ] right but
about like the the the the deepest
experiences of of like really living to
the to the to the extreme like the
decisions that this particular dude made
or life or death for real
he's not operating on her level
when i met him
he grabs my hand like like a like a
gorilla dude and just like pulls me into
this i broke my hand like in the in this
journey as well so i'm like i'm like i
actually got [ __ ] mad but i'm like
why the [ __ ] is this guy like outfitting
me right now right he's pulls me he's
like
good to see you man like nice to meet
you you're doing great but also like bro
you don't need to [ __ ] like out alpha
me like that
little dude did i know
and did i learn is like he really is a
[ __ ] like
he's he's fair he's wild dude operates
in society perfect functions or whatever
but like he he is
a true sort of primal [ __ ] yeah it's so
like what do you mean life or death
decisions what do you mean by that like
when he when he when he walked across
uh
the south pole
antarctica sorry yeah so
when he walked across antarctica by
himself you know like
and one day he actually uh took off his
glove to grab something and his finger
got frostbit and you're getting
frostbitten you're gonna lose your hand
and possibly die in antarctica what do
you do
you take a [ __ ] chisel and chop your
own finger off no he didn't yeah
whoa and and it's not like he told us
these stories either i'm very open i
said do you mind i said do you mind me
asking what happened to your half of
your finger
he goes on mate
uh south african uh no night
the way he tells the stories
you could be
in a room full of the most influential
people in the world the most powerful
people in the world
by the end of the night everyone will be
listening to my corn whoa really that's
the type of dude this was by the end he
had 15 people catching it crying
that was some of his stories
did he make you want to do that [ __ ]
a little bit like no you don't want to
climb everest not at all
that's when i realized like yo i think i
know i think i'm the [ __ ] yeah that's my
goal that's my goal yo i literally ain't
[ __ ]
i ain't [ __ ]
you could do a little kilimanjaro
sure dude
come on wait is it hard to climb to the
top of everest
it's pretty [ __ ] hard man
i thought i seen women doing it and i
didn't realize it was like a like a real
no like is it like what is i'm trying to
understand
no i mean that like
i you see you see ladies that's the
highest point dude it's super hard to
[ __ ] climb dude and mike posner just
did it yo shout out to mike bro it's
hard dude yeah people often lose their
lives knows
there's levels to this [ __ ] dude but i i
honestly thought that you could just go
do it i i genuinely thought that you
could just go rogan should have mike
horn on his podcast if you didn't
already really yeah schultz and mike
horn need to go camping together yeah i
would like to go i've never been camping
what
what
that [ __ ]
no dude never been camping no have you
camped before i'm a camper i'm waiting
for real i'm from ohio dude this is a
[ __ ] boy this is a country boy i
think i'm like a suburban he's a country
boy my dad probably like a
country boy you're a country bro i go to
school i'd be the only orange camo pants
i said no really swear only person still
get made fun of this day